are you doing I'm doing great I have to
start with so what's the secret of
playing like a in tech what's the secret
of playing a doctor in a Bond girl movie
ah Wow I don't you just gotta bring out
your inner dork I guess like you know
he's just like he's a bit of a Boy Scout
I've played a bunch of doctors over the
years which is really fun too because
you sort of get to dig it to play with
that but you see medical jargon and
stuff like that I would want no part of
that really I I have no idea what I'm
saying what I'm saying there we go
that's the secret is to look like you
know what you're talking about when you
really have no idea like a real doctor
uh I am a big fan of Tom Hardy and one
of the things that I think he does great
in this movie is he just goes for it and
every scene what is it like sharing the
screen with him and how much is he just
finding it in the moment
and you know what he's gonna do and how
much is it sort of like oh wow uh first
of all he's he's a lot of fun to work
with man because of that intensity
he loves to dig in like we had big
rehearsal sessions like with if there's
a scene coming up there's like you know
this is the overall concert of the scene
but how do we heighten it how do we get
like a little bit of humor in there how
do we make the action more intense how
do we hide in the stakes and just you
know really work it to a fever pitch
he's down to work on that like we would
talk he and and Ruben and myself and
Michelle we're in a room a couple times
for like four hours just working out the
particulars of the scene so there's a
lot of prep that goes into that and I
find that when you do that kind of work
ahead of time that when you're in the
moment it leaves you open to that
improvisation to find other things in
the moment is you're so confident in
what is here you're doing you're not
thinking about you know left foot here
right hand there you're not playing
twister so much but that you're like
you're playing jazz you know what you're
all doing you're all in sync but you're
sort of feeding off of each other and
like you know someone gets to go in one
direction while you go in the other and
the three of us had a blast playing
these scenes what do you think people
would be surprised to learn about him
making like a big comic book movie like
this I was surprised and and this is my
first you know common
so you know maybe they're all like this
but I don't think so I love the way like
the the art direction and the physical
production of this was unique and that
it was very practical like the obviously
there's CGI and there's you know there's
this big you know like graphic sequences
but everything was tangible so it wasn't
just big flats of green screen all the
time it's like they were really building
sets for the actors to sort of move
around and play around and then you get
to just sort of superimpose your own
imagination over that which is really
fun if I'm not mistaken you're in late
night you have to work with Mindy yeah
please tell me what that project was
like and getting to work with you know
on a movie that I think she wrote she
did sure she wrote a beautiful scripts I
can't wait for people to see this movie
because I think they're gonna fall in
love with it but um she approached me
early on to play this guy who's maybe
not the greatest guy in the world but he
turns out to be kind of a kind of a
decent human being it's all about the
world of late-night talk show hosts Emma
Thompson plays the the late-night talk
show host I play one of her head writers
and Mindy plays a new young sort of
starts off as an intern and comes in as
a writer she's totally the fish out of
the water and she is the girl in the you
know very closed off cloistered boys
club so it's about her sort of making
her way and along the way like she our
characters get to be friends but she
wrote such a beautiful script that
speaks on so many levels it's touching
and it's really funny emma thompson and
john lithgow are just amazing and it
hurt their okay there okay yeah yeah but
I horrible people right of course
they're really really fun to work with
of course it was great I loved it I mean
and then that the cast was amazing so
many wonderful comedic actors and
actresses throughout I think people are
really gonna dig it I cannot wait to see
it Congrats on being part of this thanks
man have a fantastic day you got
you